كان اليوم الأكثر رعبًا في حياتي منذ حوالي
شهر ، عندما أخبرني فريقي بعد يوم طويل من
الاجتماعات أننا
سنحتاج إلى 130 ألف جهاز
تهوية لأننا نفتقر إلى مئات الآلاف
من أجهزة التنفس ، هذا هو النظام الذي ورثناه
عني الذي طلب منه الحاكم  المبالغ غير المعقولة
التي لم تكن تمتلكها الحكومة الفيدرالية
، وأنت تنظر
إلى الولايات التي لم يكن لديها ولايات لم
تكن مستعدة ، كنت أعرف أن كل
شخص يحتاج إلى جهاز التنفس الصناعي ولم يحصل على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
سيموت وهذا ما كنا عليه
أخبرتهم أنهم سيموتون ، رأيت في
بلدان أخرى الأطباء يضطرون إلى اتخاذ
قرارات بشأن من حصل على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
ومن لم يفعل ، وكنت أعرف أن هذا سيكون
تحديًا محددًا للأزمة
قيل إن أولئك الذين لم يحصلوا على أجهزة التنفس الصناعي
في  موقف بديل واحد فقط
وكان ذلك هو الموت ، فهل سنتمكن من
منع الأمريكيين من الموت لأننا لم نتمكن من
الحصول على أجهزة
التنفس الصناعي وأجهزة التنفس التي يحتاجونها وكانوا
بحاجة إليها على الفور.  أنا
لتحريك السماء والأرض للتأكد من
أن هذا لم يحدث